through a roadblock in the dead of night
and into a deserted airport
this was the evacuation of Wuhan for
more than a week British nationals had
been cut off in the epicenter of the
virus as the city was effectively
quarantined they had been waiting and
waiting but when word came late on
Thursday night they had to scramble
their way out to home and to safety
plane was nearly empty though 83 British
nationals and 27 foreign nationals were
on the flight a small number in
comparison to the 747s capacity not
every British person has left NIC house
was initially and his British for those
on the plane every precaution is being
taken Sky News understands there are
three military medics and public health
England officials on board but it's
crewed by civilians the medics will have
a script to read out to people letting
them know to speak up if they feel
unwell and there'll be a special
isolation area on board this former
health secretary says flying anyone back
is a bad idea if it puts more people at
risk that one brings together people on
a plane increases the chance of their
transmitting the infection from one to
another then brings them to United
Kingdom and the you hand and the
transmission starts from there so we've
got to break the chain of transmission
therefore we must ensure there is
warranty
the situation is still desperate and
fast-moving more than 200 people have
died now from novel coronavirus a number
that keeps leaping every day there have
been no deaths outside of China but this
is now a global public health emergency
I'm declaring a public health emergency
of international concern over the global
outbreak of novel : of a corona virus
the main reason for this declaration is
not because of what is happening in
China but because of what is happening
in other countries here in Beijing the
city is in semi lockdown with unofficial
temperature checks even barricades the
people are starting to come back after
New Year holidays even bit still pretty
quiet and more people means an increased
risk of contagion and infection the
evacuation flight should land after
midday UK time those on board will be
quarantined area hospital in the world
they'll be kept there for two weeks
lockdown again but at least closer to
home
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing